he is uh he's a touchdown maker in the
playoffs unity scored a touchdown in all
three of his playoff games i mean
he's so two last year and one this year
he's still good oh yeah
so um he is uh a a revelation at the
running back position but we were on
that
we were on that when he was running
wheel routes and then no one really
really had him on their fantasy team
we were all over this kid and uh he is
dynamite now he's going to be running
for the packers at home
in an nfc championship game against a
stout
uh tampa bay buccaneer front he is aaron
jones the green bay packers how are you
aaron
i'm doing great are you i'm doing better
for talking to you how's life
how's it really i'm doing uh life is
great no complaints um
i'm blessed and glad to be talking to
you well i'm always appreciative of you
calling in
and um you know i i kind of felt for you
last week
aaron because you were the third most
talked about aaron in that game what
gives
that's ridiculous i don't like that
of all the times to be named aaron that
that that was the worst possible game
you know what i mean yeah yes sir
but i mean afterwards it wasn't too bad
well that moment you were in the end
zone it wasn't too bad either
um did you did you
what was it like going against aaron
donald was he frustrated we could we saw
he picked up a 15 yarder and obviously
was very emotional
uh aft as the rams it was obvious that
time was running out
on them what was it like uh being in
that mosh pit with him when he was out
there
aaron um i i think our offensive line
did a great job of
um limiting him you know um
i don't i think i don't know if him not
being 100 plays a role into that but
um i'm proud of our guys up front it was
i have fun
going out there competing anytime you
get to go against the best
um you see where you get to stack up
stack up at and you know
it was fun for me uh watching the game
and hearing
actual fans in the stands what was that
like for the
for for this playoff game for you man
it was amazing you know all season we
hadn't had
really any fans in limbo um and then to
come back out and i think it might have
been
eight thousand nine thousand there but
it sound they were so amped up it sound
like eighty thousand and
um i'm not making it up i'm turning
around looking like what are these
people hitting the stands with like
they're literally banging something on
the stand and it's it's loud
rocking and i loved it well yeah i guess
the the sensation
um you take it for granted all those
years and then you don't have it right
and then all of a sudden it's so
beyond appreciated aaron uh
definitely i i think that's one of the
things that was taken for granted the
most uh
fans and just how much of like an impact
they can have uh
they help with momentum and and so many
more things just bringing that extra
little energy that you need and then
obviously now you got the nfc
championship game two years in a row
um and this time however it is at home
and that's got to make a big difference
i would imagine
you know uh yes sir uh we we think it's
a
advantage being up here in lambeau uh
it's the north
it's cold up here uh we feel like not a
lot of people want to come play up here
we we're used to it we live in it we
practice in it every day
um so it is just a you got an embracing
and some mentality living up here in the
north where did you watch the um
the packer the uh the bucks saints game
aaron where'd you watch that one
on sunday i watched it at my house with
my parents
okay so did you do some scouting in a
way when you started seeing
that you knew you'd have to face either
one of these defensive fronts
you do that uh i mean i was kind of
watching the game
scouting both sides you know sure uh
you know as they're as they're playing
okay i could be playing these guys where
i could be playing these guys so you're
you're watching um both defenses as
they're playing and then you know
uh i think uh
kamar is a really good back so you get
to see how he he did against their
their defense and see some of the things
that helped him be successful
so i guess what do you do aaron jones
here or the green bay packers on the
rich eisen show
now you had played both of these teams
so you knew it was going to be a rematch
from a regular season contest one
in which you you beat the saints in in
week three
and then another uh just uh right after
that
getting absolutely boat raced out of the
spot where you hope to return
and play a super bowl and what do you do
with that film
from that game against the bucks this
week do you think what do you do with
that
um you take it you learn from it uh you
look at tendencies
um personnels
uh you also look at how you started the
game you know we
i think we came out we were up 10-0 so
um
just look at look at how you can finish
finish and continue to improve upon that
10-10-0 start
right you were up in that game and then
all of a sudden uh the the the roof
caved in
in in in tampa so did what did your
coach say after that game
what did what did uh do with with the
tape
of that week uh we watched it on you
know you
you can't just throw throw everything
out you got to watch it you got to be
critical of yourself
um but also have a short memory at the
same time and
know that hey this wasn't our standard
of football um
this wasn't our best and hopefully we
get to see this team again
and they will see our best football yeah
and just worked out like that and you
did see vitaveya on that day and it
looks like you're going to see him again
um he's coming back um from well
actually no he
he had gotten uh hurt the week before so
you're going to see him for the first
time i'm just seeing that uh well how do
you think that might change
um the uh your your
degree of difficulty aaron well i think
it always helps
you know again you're getting your main
guys back your starters especially
a key uh defender and a d tackle um
but uh you know we know it all starts up
front with us and we'll be ready to play
aaron jones here on the rich eisen show
okay um
did i see i i don't know if you you
couldn't see because i think he was
under center at the time uh it looked
like aaron rodgers was smiling
as he's looking over the defense and
calling plays you saw it
i saw a picture of that on twitter after
you saw that huh yeah he's just he
was just having a good time what was he
smarter
i couldn't imagine that do we know what
he was did you ask him
what was he smiling because he knew that
the coverage was right or he's just
looking around and just
being able to live in a moment of a big
playoff game like that what do what was
that about
can you tell i think that's when you
check to something you get the exact
look you want or something like that
that grin is just like i got you that is
definitely
a scary notion for for the other side
what what is it what's he what's he
looking like these uh last couple
weeks from your perspective uh aaron
he's just been a true leader you know
um letting all the guys know hey gotta
make the most of our opportunities this
thing doesn't come around too often
so make the most of it um play
every down like as if it's your last you
know you never know when you go out
there
well i mean if i had him on he wouldn't
talk about it so i've got a
a a big time teammate of his on can you
give me an example
of his leadership skills uh involving
either you or a teammate of yours that
he's
that he he has just uh
served with distinction in that role
with the sea on his chest
aaron jones um yeah
i mean it's so many instances day after
day uh
but i mean it could be from somebody
who's on practice squad
and him just taking the time to if the
if they're in on a rep with him him
taking the time to hey this is how it's
supposed to be
ran or this how's supposed to look and
um
he'll correct him and then and then the
next time they come out and they run it
and they do it right he gives them a
little nod that
that little that little smile that you
know and and that gives you a sense of
confidence like hey
he i'm gaining his trust i'm he knows
that i'm understanding this and he just
wants to see you
and then at the end of the day right and
how about with you or with uh
somebody who's usually in the huddle or
something like that
with him oh about that well i mean
my first interaction with him i always
say this he told me uh
i'm one of your biggest fans in this
organization and you don't know what
that can do for somebody
especially a rookie who hadn't taken a
snap coming from her future hall of
famer
um that's just one of the many i mean in
terms of
us just sitting down um on on certain
routes
hey once you get to the fourth step
do this at the top of the route and then
give me your eyes and
and so he's just you know he's helping
you evolve your game in every way not
just
not just in certain places but as a
receiver
and protection he's you know how to how
to read coverage is how to read where
the where the blitz is coming those kind
of things so
he's he's improving everybody's game
around him and how do you think he's
going to do as a host of uh jeopardy
when he gets there
aaron what do you think about that i
think he's gonna do great i think he's
gonna kill it
yeah i think he's gonna you know i mean
what gives like i'm not trying to become
a quarterback i mean like
you know hosting is kind of like my
territory will you let him know to back
off
would you do that for me
seriously like i'm not gonna sit here
and say you know what i'll give what
aaron rodgers usually does a try like i
i'm not asking you know what i mean like
just tell him uh stay in his lane if you
don't mind would you mind
i got you yeah go up to him when you see
him next say hey i was on the rich eisen
show
he was talking about uh host in jeopardy
tell him stay in his lane
okay do that for me
will you really do that though aaron are
you just laughing and saying yes will
you really do that no no i'll be like
hey hey rod uh rich told me to relate
this message for you know and then i'm
gonna let him know
yeah right yeah and let him yeah let him
know that uh
i hear his footsteps and i don't greatly
appreciate that at all
you know it's like he's smiling i'll
probably take that as a compliment
the footsteps you know okay that's true
yeah you know what i mean
yeah i don't run fast aaron but i mean
at least i but i run
fast when i host you know what i mean if
if if hosting was running i run a 4-4
and that's the way i've i'm coming out
of the smoke i get very competitive
when it comes to that i i think i think
it's more like a 4-3
you're a little bit lower than that i
appreciate that i'm a tremendous slouch
i understand what you're saying
so uh leflore how does how has the coach
helped you in your game
you just told me how aaron rodgers told
you x y and z and how it's improved you
but what about
the coach who seems to get no run here
for any coach of the year even though
there's back to back 13 and three
seasons what about matt laflin oh yes
sir
uh coach lafleur he's just really gave
me a chance to uh show what i can do and
um turning me into the full-time starter
uh
before he came out when the full-time
starter split on
and then just uh you know sean as well
as showing what you can do and
um running the ball protecting and then
also as a receiver gotten so many more
opportunities as a receiver
um and just to show that i'm a i'm a
well-rounded back and that
i can do everything and just the uh
opportunities
that he he brought well again you know
just before i let you go here
um your kid from texas right and um
and now you're up there in wisconsin and
you're going to be playing in a big time
playoff game in
in lambeau field uh in in in the nfc
championship game this is the stuff
that's
dreams come true um and you're you know
you're
you're a pro bowl runner of note in your
own right
i i say all that by asking you if i had
told you growing up
that you could deny tom brady
a victory in what's maybe for him the
most important game of his
career i know he's won super bowls and
they're all very important to him
but this one to get to the super bowl at
home
nobody's ever done that before and to do
it in his first year outside of new
england this is very particularly
important to him
and you have the ability to prevent it
with your play if i had told that to
that kid
what would you have said uh
i would have believed you i just
wouldn't have maybe thought it was tom
brady out of like
who knows what quarterback is going to
be um but i would have believed you i
mean
i believe in myself uh since i was a
little kid i told my parents i want to
play an nfl or nba
um i want to be a a super bowl champion
i want to be a pro ball i want to be
you know all these things so um i
believe if you if you think it and you
and you believe it and you talk it
into existence and manifest it it'll
happen i love it
which nba team which which which what
was your position
aaron point guard shooting guard where
were you what are you going for i played
point guard and shooting guard
yes sir play both okay it didn't matter
what team drafted me i just wanted to
play in the nba
and so how did the nfl get get you over
the nba did you just you you you noticed
you had a better
skills at the uh the oblong ball than
the round one is that what you're saying
pretty much
or what um a little bit of that uh you
know my size
isn't the best for basketball uh okay
and then
i was playing way more and once i got to
college i was playing way more in
football than i was in basketball and i
looked at the numbers on the rosters and
i'm like
it's only 15 guys here and it's 53-63
over here so
i stand a better chance of making over
here math okay but so but you could fill
it up is what you're saying though
given an opportunity oh yes sir yes sir
[Laughter]
yes sir okay so from three i mean what's
your what's
what's your record for most threes in
the game then aaron jones
most threes in the game i think i've hit
five in a game five or six
all right is that why that that your
number is the way it is there's threes
all over the place is that what it is
now i'll provide attack the basket okay
oh all right go to the rim
i've noticed that that's part of your
game you you you definitely go to the
figurative rim in the
in the nfl uh i always love our chats
aaron congrats again on
another playoff victory for you and
another nfc championship game
for you knocking on the door with aaron
rodgers this is uh
this is uh a blessing in the nfl and
enjoy it
good luck to you yes sir thank you a
huge blessing and thank you for having
me again
always and again what are you going to
tell aaron rodgers when you see him
later what are you going to tell him
i'm going to tell him that you hear his
footsteps
back off this that's your lane stay in
your yes
that's my lane stay in your lane
aaron rodgers okay please do that please
do that
yes sir i got you you got it take care
that's aaron jones everybody green bay
packers
pro bowl running back that's amazing hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here